en de celle de georges marchais qui
aujourd'hui encore a défendu cette thèse
devant les employés de bureau et grands
magasins de paris en plein coeur de la
capitale c'était sa deuxième rencontre
sur le terrain avec des travailleurs
parisien bruno alba était là
35 heures moins de chômeurs affirme le
candidat du parti communiste français et
de la répéter aujourd'hui au meeting qui
tenait rue caumartin des employés de
bureau des vendeurs une corporation qui
tombe trois cent mille personnes dans la
région parisienne essentiellement des
femmes alors les employés qui
subissaient les pats salaires la
précarité de l'emploi
les 35 heures à répéter georges marchais
il convient de les imposer mais il
convient aussi de ne pas se laisser
prendre par les belles paroles la
réduction du temps de travail ne doit
pas aboutir dit il pour le patronat à la
possibilité d'organiser les horaires
comme il le voudrait
pour georges marchais la semaine de 35
heures 100 ans avec le maintien du
pouvoir d'achat du salaire antérieur
quant au financement de cet objectif
georges marchais préconise le seul qui
lui paraît efficace est possible il faut
vite ils s'en prendront aux profits des
patrons